this is Steve McGranahan the self dub
world's strongest redneck this is an 8
pound bowling ball yes Steve racked up
over 8 million hits with his online
physics experiments fishing hole warning
about physics I can't tell you how many
times I sat around a fishing hole
thinking about physics about how a mass
object can travel through lesser objects
I'm glad Steve thought about the physics
before he did this experiment because if
he did he wouldn't be a redneck he'd be
a dead nicht so how did Steve avoid the
dreaded split ya skull Steve is
protected by those five plates when the
bowling ball hits the plates they crack
surprise and that's good because that
absorbs some of the energy but secondly
and most importantly is actually being
slowed down over a larger distance a
little bit like a crumple zone in a car
without the plates that bowling ball
would have to slow down from 16
kilometers per hour or 10 miles an hour
down to zero in just a few milliseconds
and a lot of deceleration by mass is a
lot of force but with the plates there
it takes a lot longer all of that force
is spread out across the place and
that's what saves Steve good stuff but
remember Steve is the world's strongest
redneck so do not try this at home